you know who texted me uh during those
tennis matches is natalie mayne's i
hadn't heard from her in forever and she
said i'm watching tennis and there's a
baba booey look-alike winning she goes
everyone is saying it's baba bowie who
is that italian guy
carlos
carlos uh alcarez looks like gary i
don't know she was saying the guy i
don't know who she was saying the guy
who won
everything
i don't know i don't know
who is 19 years old and he doesn't have
a big
mustache
she tried he looked like gary he has big
teeth but i said carlos alcarez looks
like gary and natalie's very um very
obsessed with you gary oh yeah very well
aware yeah well really you talk on the
wrap-up show a lot about how my
ethnicity could be any of a million
things
yeah and so we went to go on this tour
and
the woman immediately starts speaking to
me in portuguese and i'm like yeah i
don't speak portuguese i don't know what
to say
what is that i mean you you and and it
seems to me that people
pin almost any ethnicity on you other
than italian
i said to mary we were there i go is
there no ethnicity i can't represent she
goes yeah swedish
she's right the greatest one ever was i
got into a fender bender with a guy in
the city and he got out of his car and
he just goes
you greasy [ __ ] are all the
same and then he took off and i was like
i wonder which greasy [ __ ] he
thinks i am
i like when you went to the today show
yes it was just when those chilean
miners had all been rescued and they had
all the chilean miners on and gary was
there for something completely different
and they were rounding everyone up he
almost got swept into the group
i was so mad at him i was so mad at him
because i wanted him to go on the today
show with one of the chilean miners
i didn't even understand what was
happening so before the show the people
that are going to talk to you come out
and chat with you so natalie morales
comes out and she just starts speaking
spanish really quickly and i was like i
don't speak spanish and she goes oh
but behind me was the chilean miner who
was easily four inches shorter than me
and then she just went to him and talked
to him